I just heard like back in the day man
like I would always like guys like uh
would I wouldn't even say their names
but just I heard like way way back
probably even
Rock Radio Days like used to be able to
like get your record on if you dropped
off like a a eight ball of cocaine
you're like some of these like rock PDS
in the 70s you know yo man it was it was
a different it was a different
environment because
um when I got to when I later became the
PD of jbtn Sol gotta remember Sol's on
the urban adult panel and jbt at the
time was on the rhythmic panel not the
urban panel it was on the urban panel of
course yes and jbt is on the rhythmic
panel so I I'd come from St Louis at km
Jam so I knew every you know all the
urban people so
now I have this whole slew of people
that I don't know most of whom are white
and you talking about the record reps
yeah and it's a totally different vibe
right like I I was I remember Hitman
Hayes who's in um he's in San Diego San
Diego now was my music director at the
time I remember walking to his office
one time to ask him and he's on speaker
and some dude is just like yelling at
him like oh you [__]
yeah and I was like so that's like you
that's like yo who who is that it was
it's a record guy oh I said and he's
talking to you like that he said yeah I
was like hang up on him
he said believe me I said hang up you
got it yeah I just hung up on him I was
like man like I don't ever want to hear
you letting somebody talk to you like
that again I'll fire you you know what
I'm saying and uh you know our
relationship was great at that moment he
still works in the company he was great
but it was just so different to see how
you know the Reps were different and you
know it was great for me because I had
an opportunity to meet all of those
people and I've had relation
long-standing relationships with people
on both sides of the equation but yeah
even me like when I got hired it real
technically yeah it was the first urban
State ever worked so obviously worked at
tons of hip-hop stations but there's
hip-hop stations on the Rhythm path yeah
yeah so coming to Rio yeah I'm beating
all these record reps you know I had
before I had never had relationships
like I like Dwight or you know guys
exactly there's like a whole new group
of guys and we should probably explain
the whole idea between rhythmic and
urban correct so for people who don't
know yeah Hot 97 is a hip-hop station
but it's on the Rhythm panel yeah so
there's a rhythmic chart and there's a I
believe around 60 stations that report
to it probably give or take right so
Power 106 in La that we're smoking in
the ratings uh Hot 97 in New York those
are hip-hop stations that are on the
rhythmic panel got it on the urban panel
yeah there's a ton of stations on the
urban panel a lot more stations right
um
typically but there's a story behind
that too yeah what is that story story
behind that is let's just keep it real
rhythmic stations play predominantly
black people hip-hop 100 most of the
jocks are white most of the program
directors are white and then out of
touch and weird and cringiest I'm not
trying I'm just I'm trying to just no
you're just the facts listen and so then
on the urban panel
most of the majority of people most of
the talents most of the programs
directors of black and on the record
side most of those people are people of
color so here I am I started overseeing
the urbans for the company in 2000 and
around 2003 was the first time we
decided to launch power in New York and
working with Steve Smith Tom Pullman
who's still on us that's crazy Steve
Smith helped launch that station yeah
and he launched HOT97 that was my guy
rip God bless the soul yeah and so then
the conversation comes up and they're
like okay so yeah we're gonna put it on
the uh rhythmic panel like oh no no no
no no no no
not me yeah I'm the head of urban yeah
black to New York City this is my city
I'm not putting a hip-hop station on and
putting it on the Ripley panel and they
just it the conversation was literally
about two seconds and that's one of the
things about I loved about Tom to this
day at the time you're like you're right
it should be and so then fast forward 15
years later we get ready to launch real
same thing
two second conversation nope I don't do
that like so what they wanted you to run
it at on the Rhythm panel yeah oh wow
but that that's jobs man you know we
create jobs when we put an urban on it
no for sure and power is still in urban
we created jobs when we put
um real on in La same thing in Houston
with the beat same thing in Miami with
the beat same thing
um but one of those things I know for me
personally was important for me to do
and it was important that our company
supported us because I was like like
that's crazy like why would why would we
do that yeah it doesn't make any sense
and I always didn't understand the
this is like kind of getting into some
inside baseball but I never really
understood
the lack of Urban's
on the west coast in general like I
think of a station like KMEL right it's
an urban station but it's not it's on
the Rhythm panel yeah you know but it's
like that's a
it's like is that I think that might be
the first hip-hop station
Cameo on the west coast I think it was
the first
it might have been I think so I'd have
to do much but it's just but yeah it's
some real radio nerd [__] but it's
definitely like if you're an artist
right and like maybe you are because a
lot of up and coming artists watch the
podcast like
you're you've got to kind of make a
decision if you have a record and you
have a budget which chart you're going
to chase right so it's like I want to go
to the rhythmic side I want to go on the
urban side I'm going to go on the top 40
side and then you make a decision from
there yeah it's it's actually crazy
because when if you looked at our
playlist for real in La we have rhythmic
sensibilities for sure where's Bad Bunny
getting played Steve Lacy you know for
sure and it's a function of our audience
100 you know our audience here is
predominantly Latino with some
African-Americans and you know you go to
Atlanta it's totally different you go to
La I mean go to New York it's totally
different and you know usually the
playlist is a function of the diet that
that audience was fed upon we're here in
here in La the diet was more rhythmic
right and so as you put a station on
here in La gradually like when I
launched it we launched it like it was a
urban station but gradually it's begun
to take on it's like its own thing yeah
yeah its own thing because of the
feedback from the audience